bonsoir monsieur robert beck quel est
l'effet de la guerre en ukraine sur les
producteurs chez vous ça va entraîner
une augmentation de prix comme vous
l'avez constaté tantôt
l'élément qui est important de confiance
dans les deux dernières années une des
difficultés de production pour notre
consommation mondiale qui est en
augmentation donc ça allait amener des
stocks d'un rapport relativement faibles
ou séries et ça l'a amené là en effet
d'entraînement sur l'augmentation de la
valeur des grands disons que la guerre
ukraine russie amène une inquiétude
supplémentaire qui n'était pas souhaitée
c'était pas souhaité est-ce que c'est
déjà constatée est ce qu'on s'en rend
déjà compte et est-ce qu'on parmi les
membres et les producteurs on en une
vive inquiétude présentement bon on vit
présentement les mains premier que la
d'augmentation et partant du prix de des
grains qu'on a un éventail les
inventaires qu'on ne pas encore de jeu
convenu de le mettre en marche et il y
en a plus y en actions de ses valeurs
l'eau mais d'un autre côté c'est la
grande période des achats d'un train
spécialement des engrais minéraux puis
là aussi on a constaté depuis l'été
passé finalement une augmentation
importante de la valeur de ces engrais
l'eau due aux conséquences que cela a
entraîné les différences ouragans aux
états unis cela a amené la fermeture de
certaines usines de production donc une
appréciation de la valeur parce que
l'offre est à - méla des prix des grains
qui manquent et des prix des engrais qui
manque c'est quoi la répercussion sur
les producteurs ben ça nous amène un
niveau de stress supplémentaire
appartint parce que ça amène des
difficultés analyse au niveau des
marchés tant sur la vente de nos grains
que sur une acquisition d un agréé puis
aussi l'élément nouveau des engrais est
ce qu'on va être certain d'avoir
l'ensemble des fournitures qui nous
seront nécessaires d'ici le mois de juin
2022 pourquoi bas parce que si le canada
décidé de restreindre des importations
russes de différents produits dont les
engrais ou si monsieur poutine sai ses
exportations en réaction au burck
financier qu'on lui impose
ça nous fait un fournisseur de moyen
terme d'angré parce que le bloc russe
est un important producteur du ried de
phosphorer d'importance on en importe
beaucoup de ça mais de kannad atteint
principalement exportateurs un niveau
d'apd asthme un très grand importateur
renouveau de gaz hotte et du soin soir
et donc on va se tourner vers qui vers
quoi beloeil des gens aussi d'un haut
niveau nos distributeurs se sont tournés
vers d'autres fournisseurs d'un train de
tout marché nord américain puisque le
marché d'europe et est incertain étant
ici
vous comprendrez de tout ce qui était à
l'aise de l'europe ben c'est comme
impossible de faire une bise venue selon
un commerce situé rita est dans ce sens
que c'est parce que les
approvisionnements mois de garantie
ouais est ce que quelque part les
producteurs de grains bénéficie profite
d'une hausse du prix comme c'est le cas
présentement pour le blé par exemple si
on fait le calcul chapeau d'autres
choses qui bougent de beaucoup de ces
vrai que notre marge bénéficiaire avoir
atteint argumentation là pour l'année
2022 mais faut s'assurer d'avoir l'eau
des êtres qui nous sont nécessaires mais
sachant l'importance de l'ukraine et de
la russie dans le marché de
l'exportation de blé de maïs également
mais de blé est ce que nous au canada on
pourrait remplacer ce marché abandonné
par par l'ukraine par la russie c'est là
ma judas mondialisation laïb aura des
échanges des gens ce qui importe qui
exportent puis finalement à la fin on
peut imaginer que les mêmes volumes vont
être transigées puisqu'ils y ont
nécessité le dos à ce que tout le monde
peut se nourrir convenablement donc les
varois régimes politiques qui vont se
faire pour que tout le monde se nourrit
mais avec des éléments d'inquiétude au
niveau de la planification des
exportations est ce que ça veut dire que
nos exportations vont augmenter savoir
qu en fonction la production qu'on va
réussir à faire un journal l'année 2022
il faut comprendre qu'à 21 doit s
canadiens suivent une très grave
sécheresse de diminuer de environ la
moitié nos exportations vers les autres
pays au travail de la planète donc si on
a une belle saison 2022 l'ensemble des
canadiens réussissent bien récolte on va
pouvoir reprendre notre place lors sur
l'échiquier mondial et qu'est ce que ça
veut dire pour les prix de la farine
pour les prix des produits de la
boulangerie les prix de la viande
également parce qu'il faut nourrir les
bêtes avec les grains il faut comprendre
que les grains c'est là-bas aux lieux de
toute une agriculture qui est québécois
ou canadiens nous mondial donc une
augmentation de la valeur de ces
intrants à l'eau pour les autres sites
de production pour la transformation
d'un secteur de la boulangerie ça va
amener une certaine forme d'augmentation
lors d'un de leurs coûts qui vont être
transmises auprès des consommateurs
ouais alors un petit choc inflationniste
de plus sur les prix des aliments à
prévoir est ce que vous êtes d'avis que
les chaînes d'approvisionnement qu'on a
bâtie au fil du temps sont en train de
se dérégler complètement mais je pense
que la guerre allait occasionner une g 7
sud au niveau de la mondialisation des
marchés puis en train je pense que de
remettre un peu en question le confort
que la mondialisation nous avait amené
dans les échanges commerciaux donc tous
or je pense ça amène un niveau
d'inquiétude que les grandes entreprises
comme les petits producteurs locaux la
ramener des inquiétudes dans l'émoi mais
c'est au verdict merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec lui
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
m